thank you for joining us I'm John  langler this this morning the mayor  called for a curfew Las Vegas mayor  Carolyn Goodman demanded a response to  the increasing violence on Fremont  Street downtown her statement comes  after several shootings including a  deadly attack two weeks ago Metro Police  are still looking for the suspect in a  shooting over the weekend as well mayor  Goodman says there will be more law  enforcement in and around the Fremont  Street Experience moving forward in a  tweet this morning mayor Goodman adds  she has met with Metro Police to discuss  she says the idea of a curfew on Fremont  for people under 21. should point out  city law already shows a curfew exists  for children under 18 from 9 to 5 9 pm  to 5 a.m Fridays and Saturdays 10 P.M to  5 a.m Sunday through Thursday more on  this story throughout the day